this tortilla Pizza is a seemingly basic
recipe but it's one that's close to my
heart during my masters I used to go
over to my two close friends's house
where we cooked and ate together we
looked for simple cheap quick recipes
and born out of that necessity came this
28 Pizza I'm not at University anymore
but all these years later one of those
two friends runs an organic foods brand
and the other one Cooks some of the best
carite food I have ever seen but I still
think that the origin story of our
combined love for food came from this
humble student recipe here are three
easy healthy veg snacks that are better
than a of chips first up Lotus seeds or
makana these crunchy little things are
delicious quick and easy once they heat
it up add some salt chili powder chat
Masala they're super crunchy next up
let's make some rice cakes these are
also really versatile I'm adding
avocados Tomatoes Salt and Pepper to
keep things simple so there's an endless
list of things you can do with them
third let's make a really simple Moon
salad the mo itself was left to sprout
in water for 2 days and with some salt
onion tomato lemon it's so easy to put
together